welcome to this video and playing Guinea
um from the US I'm intending to play the
Slav and we get a small not the exchange
yellow I play that myself of course now
you can see what the big antidote I have
against the exchange okay is playing for
win with III so hmm Bishop f5 is this
some is this too ambitious maybe up
until that scientists rhyme
yeah why couldnt be three what the heck
am i doing against it Knight a5 this
Bishop b5 check and Bishop d7 he can
take on d5 yeah this was stupid I mean I
know that this move is always the
problem hmm Wow yeah how idiotic can you
be you know that this is not working any
plane anyway ah so what should I do here
maybe Queen B section night be 595 Queen
B 5 queen bee to very quickly played hmm
does this so clear-cut
I mean I'm willing to believe that why
does better here of course but he played
it really quickly maybe it's it's all
known as sir it's very bad for black so
this is very much possible okay so let's
see I go you sick so probably I need to
play e6 yeah the spinning the spinning
business is very annoying but we should
be fine I probably need to retreat the
special e6 coin be five if I don't
really see what to do against against
this and while the retreat is not very
inspiring I'm aware of that but maybe I
get an e6 Bishop deform to exchange
stuff yeah this is really all yeah born
out of necessity or simply I simply
blundered Bishop f5 I mean I'm actually
I'm really aware that is not good but I
play it anyway sometimes it's really
strange but maybe I'm it's not not so
terrible maybe
ok so we six is the idea and now Bishop
to b4 its not bad actually 13e Quincy
one cannot take it cannot take I said
let's just briefly reconsider and I can
check and just take the rook and then so
you see somehow making me if I take the
the second book on hmm yeah that's
that's take it I really don't see I
cannot really believe that I should be
mated him simply because yeah this one
was hanging and therefore I cannot cut
off my McQueen so I can take g2 I can go
back let's say to see one d 5 is of
course a move maybe I should go here so
that after d 5 I take a 2 is check and
Grandpa d5 yeah this is a good move and
then also even without a playing deep
fear he'd actually blunders in this
check I can almost primo vit
yet light resign this was lucky I guess
I guess after I played this idiotic move
Bishop f5 his thought that there's some
complete non complete putzi on the other
side this is not bad actually this night
h5 business and this was just a bit of
teasing to draw back if you play a bit
more viciously ago e6 en player 5 which
I normally do I actually expected him to
play this and then after doing this I
would've played e6 but he played III and
here yeah but I can just play e6 and
okay he's lost a move here with Bishop
d2 or white has an additional move but
the position is so close that without
the bishops out of the pawn chain it's
very equal but this is just just just a
stupid move and I'm in trouble here it's
um maybe Luke patm the computer suggests
through piayed of course um it's a
important issue that does not Bishop f4
coming yeah this actually is playable
and here i can just take on b6 a few
months but the computer likes this
actually at first at least yeah wow the
computer wants to play Bishop b5 here
cool
yeah if I can't then it gets very tricky
this is a big threat check check check
mate mm-hmm okay so on I need you to
play play differently oops I need to do
something else maybe I need two together
with Bishop d7 again or loop c8
something along these lines of course
this is much better than the game this
is quite obvious already because he gets
a very smooth development and here this
is Sir the IE six is better going to the
comp I didn't really like this position
yeah computer just wants to develop and
give up the porn oops 16 near impossible
now I'd I retreated and this is the
night before is also strong him I didn't
see that at all but he i'm at least them
I'm in decent shape he should castle
though something like that and why this
is somewhat better yeah this is just
blunder shopping blunder of the house I
guess you really thought that some brain
dead person must be on the other side
after the opening I don't know just just
blundered to looks basically yeah very
lucky very lucky break for me alright
thanks for watching